wow wow wow
wow
[Music]
hey guys it's inka i am back again to do
some crazy mixing things
a day has challenged me to mix a bunch
of things before
like mixing every type of cereal every
kind of cookie mix every kind of cake
mix
every kind of chips and this time he's
challenged me
to mix every kind of valentine's
chocolate that he could possibly find
into a box of chocolates i don't think
i've ever received
valentine's day chocolates before on
valentine's day so this is also really
interesting for me to actually see
what's out there so i'm gonna see what
i'm gonna be working with
all right first chocolate we have is
hershey's milk chocolate heart this is
so cute
oh my goodness okay this is snickers
twix and milky way it looks more like a
variety pack
ooh this one looks like it would kill me
this is
dove assorted chocolates
this is a variety pack with reese's
hershey
and kit kat woo hoo this is
another dove chocolate
this is hershey's kisses oh no there's
kisses and more kisses
okay how do you pronounce this
ghirardelli girodelli ghirardelli
oh this is lint
hershey's and m m's this is from godiva
oh another godiva one this is another
one from
garrett billy ferrero collections
oh my god this is from russell
stover all right we have another
heart-shaped one
also from reese's is
a chocolate ruby chocolate so i don't
believe this is a valentine's day
chocolate
[Music]
but it's ruby chocolate it's like
naturally pink
18 different packets here but a lot more
flavors to work with so
i'm gonna pull out my mixing bowl and
we're gonna start
chopping these up so here's my game plan
i have a bunch of chocolates here
i have my bowl i'm gonna take one of
each chocolate
put this in the bowl ideally maybe
around one tablespoon or one of each
flavor so we get a little bit of each
and then i'm gonna melt it all down and
then i'm going to
put them in these heart-shaped molds
which will then
harden i can then present them in a nice
new box starting with this first one
races hershey's
and kitkats and the reason i'm chopping
them up is just because
later on for melting purposes it's going
to make the process
faster next up we have the lava cake
hershey kisses like a liquid center
kisses number two these are the
meltaways
i feel like it's gonna be a little more
like the truffle center
i'm really excited about this one the
godiva assorted chocolate creations so
there's nine different types of
chocolate in here
oh this one has it's like honey infused
caramel
this one is a dark chocolate raspberry
velvet
i don't think this is going to add any
color to our mostly brown
color palette here but i do think some
fruitiness would be nice
next up i have one big hershey kiss
a fun concept if you want to give
somebody just a big
kiss the hershey's and the reese's you
can actually write down
who it's for who it's from there's a lot
of hershey's chocolate
so far next up we have very deli
chocolates
comes in pink blue and gold this one is
milk chocolate
caramel this one
is a white chocolate it smells like
butterscotch
this one is dark chocolate sea salt
caramel you always want some salt
to complement your sweet desserts
this is the giant combo package this is
cute
i like this i feel like these are going
to be a little hard to melt down
i'm just going to put one of each color
in here snickers
just chop off a little bit at the ends
here twix
look at that that's the biscuit crunch
dove truffles dark chocolate next up is
ferrero collection here's the signature
i like that this has hazelnuts this is
the white one
it's covered in coconut those tropical
flavors
this one has like chocolate drizzle on
top it's coated in like little chocolate
drops no putting a little bit of each in
there
here is the one that has eight different
flavors
lots of chocolates here oh yeah
this is strawberry cream very nice for
color
purposes this is toffee toffee in
desserts honestly
it adds so much flavor love love
love godiva assorted chocolate there's
dark chocolate double chocolate
and milk chocolate crispy hazelnut i
really hope these kinds of chocolates
gives it
a more like truffle texture here's the
ghirardelli
sweethearts premium chocolate assortment
look at it
wow so now i'm just going to chop these
all up since they're all truffles
i feel like they're all things that
we've had already so i'm not going to go
too in depth here
next up is the dove chocolate creamy
caramel milk chocolate hearts dark
chocolate truffle hearts there's like
little messages at the bottom this one
says love
the small things follow your heart you
are lovable
is this for you to buy for other people
or for you to buy for yourself this
feels like messages for yourself
an assessment of what we have so far i
feel like we're getting a lot of
caramel and a lot of truffles i'm hoping
that all these like plain chocolate ones
will help balance out the other ones
lynch is probably the chocolate
brand that i eat the most six different
flavors i think for this one it's less
about the
texture obviously but you do get a wide
range of
chocolates that brings us to
our last chocolate which is
the ruby chocolate so what's really cool
about it right is that it is
completely natural you see this
beautiful pink color
in my opinion i think it tastes more
like white chocolate chop chop chop
chop and in great
and so here we are my bowl of
valentine's day chocolates doesn't look
very valentine's day right now
looks more brown than anything else but
i'm gonna
reset the table get my double boiler
going and we can start
melting and tempering this i'm back with
a beautiful pink pot to fit the themes
of today
of valentine's love yada yada
i'm going to melt this down using the
double boiler method i could pop this in
the microwave but because there's like
a lot of chocolate in here i kind of
want to see how it melts down
but i'm going to try and take out a
third of the chocolate here which i'll
use to temper
the rest of the melted chocolate later
[Music]
i just broke it this is fantastic you
guys
um all right i want to get it up to
around 110 fahrenheit
just trying to melt this down i feel
like it's going to be an interesting
process constant movement constant
movement i don't want it to burn either
oh it's 110 all right we good i'm gonna
toss this in now
to bring down the temperature there we
go
now i'm trying to bring it back down to
around 85
which is the tempering process there's
still quite a bit of lumps going on
again all that texture i was talking
about
smells like milk chocolate and white
chocolate
more than it does anything else i guess
i'm getting a little bit of caramel but
not
too much
so i brought the chocolate down to 85
degrees fahrenheit brought it up again
to around 89 so now it has this
melted consistency it is not as smooth
obviously as i would like it to be
i'm gonna scoop this now into my piping
bag
there we go piping is supposed to make
it easier
which is why i am doing it and i can
always just scrape off the chocolate
later now i just need to do the same
thing for
the other one
let's move it out i think we're looking
pretty good
all right we have two trays
of chocolate here cool i totally forgot
to taste this
when it's all melted so i'm gonna give
it a little taste now
i think the first thing that came to
mind was caramel
the chocolate is really interesting in
terms of the texture
so it's like caramel infused with
chocolate can you taste the love
do i taste the love i don't know we'll
see
i don't taste it right now in this form
but i feel like in its final
form maybe it has been a couple minutes
the chocolate has now
set so i'm gonna try and get them out
maybe this is not the best way to do it
silicone ones
should be easier so i'm gonna peel this
off
this came out better than i expected
i'm actually going to brush on gold dust
that i bought it is an edible gold dust
it's actually
made using chocolate powder
these look so good
and i'm really excited now to pack it in
my
chocolate box i'm gonna get a pair of
fake chopsticks
because i don't want to melt it
[Music]
last one boom
i think there's like over 40 flavors
maybe
but look at this wow
i'm honestly i have to say i am pretty
impressed by the chocolate i shall give
it a try
whoa i was expecting some sort of like
bite but i think because there were so
many
truffles so much of that caramel filling
the praline
when i bite into it it's almost like a
fudgy consistency
it's like a soft velvety texture which
is actually
really pleasing wow i'm going to try one
of the gold ones
just because i'm curious honestly it
doesn't taste too different
i think because the edible dust is also
technically
chocolate complements it very well it's
just chocolate on chocolate maybe a cool
little fun project to try at home i
think it's fairly easy edible gold dust
saves the day
and um that's about it mixing chocolate
into one box of valentine's day
chocolate i hope you guys enjoyed
watching this
and see you guys next time
you